okay a ton has been made of a recent
report that says Oh $15 minimum wage
would destroy more than 1 million jobs
and this report is being cited by
right-wingers all over the country as
proof proof that a $15 minimum wage
would be terrible for the country and we
shouldn't do it and in fact this is
being used to argue that we shouldn't
even have a minimum wage at all
because it's an artificial price floor
and it's bad for the economy so I want
to actually talk this through with you
today because you might be shocked to
hear this but the right-wing reaction to
this study makes no sense at all and is
patently dishonest so let's start with
what this study says right now the
federal minimum wage is $7.25 an hour
which is insane I often forget about
this because I live in Massachusetts but
federally even though many states have
higher minimum wages federally the
minimum wage is $7.25 an hour the study
by the CBO looked at increases to $10 an
hour $12 an hour and $15 an hour by 2025
we're just gonna focus on the 15 an hour
to keep it simple today increasing the
minimum wage to $15 by 2025
the CBO study found would increase the
effective net wages of 17 million people
who would otherwise be earning under $15
an hour that's good news
in addition to raising the wages of 17
million who would be earning under $15
an hour it would also push up slightly
the wages of another 10 million people
who are earning right around 15 or will
be earning right around $15 an hour
in 2025 so 27 million people in total
will have higher wages as a result of
this minimum-wage increase however about
1.3 million people would be moved would
would not have a job who otherwise would
people it doesn't necessarily mean
people will be fired but it means that
in 2025 with a $15 minimum wage there
are 1.3 million people who would
otherwise have jobs who will not because
of that minimum wage increase and it
would have a slightly inflationary
effect on prices overall
first of all we have to understand that
these numbers the CBO admits are
uncertain because the CBO straight-up
admits we don't know how responsive
unemployment or employment are to
changes in the minimum wage they admit
there is a lot of uncertainty about how
sensitive is employment relative to a
change in the minimum wage is it
extremely sensitive or is it only
slightly sensitive in addition there are
other studies published at the exact
same time that say there would not be
this effect of 1.3 million jobs that
would not exist were it not for that $15
minimum wage but for this discussion
let's imagine that these numbers are
100% accurate from the CBO the question
becomes does it make sense to increase
the minimum wage to $15 or not so the
most childish argument is any policy
that leads to any job loss is a bad
policy now this is an outrageous
position to take because almost any
economic policy decision has some gains
in some losses and you basically can't
do anything I mean the government would
not be able to do any economic policy if
the rule was if any jobs are lost we
don't do it so that's not even a serious
argument it is true that to come in and
in some states you would be effectively
more than doubling the minimum wage that
is going to affect employers more if the
wage than if the wage had been
increasing with inflation all along and
that's part of the problem here we are
so far behind on minimum wage increases
in states that still have a minimum wage
that is equal to the federal minimum
wage of 725 that we now have a situation
we're going to $15 would more than
double the minimum wage in some states
so this is how you have an adult
conversation there is a benefit to the
policy but it also comes with a cost is
the cost too high is the cost acceptable
is it low and we get a lot more benefit
than we lose by putting in place this
policy when you look at where a $15
minimum wage would have the biggest
impact you immediately see that the
gains will be in the places where people
much more desperately need
in terms of wage growth and the job
losses will also be disproportionately
in the places that are so far behind on
the minimum wage right now that going to
$15 would be effectively doubling the
minimum wage in their state so can I
answer for you whether it makes sense in
your state to have this trade-off I
can't really do that can I answer
whether 27 million people getting a
raise and pulling about 2 million people
out of poverty is that a valuable
trade-off is it a fair trade-off for 1.3
million not having jobs in 20 25 who
otherwise would know I can't really tell
you that I mean each of us has different
priorities what I can tell you
definitively is that this exposes the
bigger truth about the minimum wage
which I've been talking about for years
now the first bigger truth is that this
is really an issue that probably has to
vary state by state and what I mean by
that is that because the cost of living
is so drastically different in different
parts of the country and even within
states like for example New York State
which has New York City and extremely
rural low cost of living areas upstate a
living wage in some low cost of living
states would be too low to even be a
reasonable minimum wage in a place that
has a high cost of living like New York
City or Boston San Francisco Los Angeles
so I question even handling this as a
federal issue even though a 725 federal
minimum wage is outrageously low and
that needs to change
the second bigger truth here is that
this once again gets to what I said to a
caller last week when they said does the
$15 minimum wage or does this universal
basic income does that really solve the
problem that we are dealing with and the
answer is that these are not solutions
to our broken economy particularly with
automation coming 40 years of
productivity gains going to the richest
people while the bottom half have
effectively stagnant wages increased
inequality the solution is not going to
be a $15 minimum wage the solution is
not going to be universal basic income
now that doesn't mean don't do them okay
but what it does mean is that we need to
all understand
to really solve our problems we've got
to be thinking way bigger and almost
none of our politicians are now Andrew
yang is actually talking about this I
just don't agree with all of his
proposals I think that the VAT tax
proposal he has that's a hugely
regressive tax I don't like that I think
that the implementation of some of his
other ideas is the wrong one but he is
at least talking about it last thing
really important to understand on the
back end that again the numbers we used
for our discussion today might be
totally wrong because there's a
University of California study which
says that a $15 minimum wage by 2024
simply would not cause the level of job
losses that the CBO study claims so
there is a conflict there but it doesn't
matter
because none of it solves the reality
that we have a broken relationship
between humans and work this includes
this average 40-hour five day a week
workweek this includes the connection
between work and healthcare that we have
and it includes
the fact that the economy values at zero
a lot of work that has value like
raising kids taking care of our elderly
parents volunteering in our communities
and whether the minimum wage is 10 12 or
15 dollars that is still going to be a
problem one of today's sponsors is
impeach the card slap game you can't
slap Donald Trump in real life but you
can slap them in this really funny and
intelligent two-player card game and you
can get it for 10% off at david
pakman.com slash impeach impeach the
card game is perfect for having friends
over hanging out with family members who
have a sense of humor about trump we've
been playing it at my place I really
don't think you'd be able to find a game
that does a better job of satirizing
today's political climate in such an
intelligent way I've had a ton of fun
with it I think you will too
you can tell a ton of time and careful
thought went into the game design and
the cartoon artwork and the humor it
never gets old because you're always
discovering new jokes and political
commentary in the game we were talking
to the creators of the game and they
said one of the goals was that players
might even learn something new as they
play I think it would make a perfect
gift for anyone really of any political
orientation because of how clever it is
and when you go to david pakman.com
slash in peach you'll get 10% off the
game but you can also get 10% off any of
the
Arius clothing and accessories in the
online store including t-shirts coffee
mugs tote bags all featuring funny
original political cartoons about the
president get a super fun and witty gift
for yourself or someone you know whether
it's impeach the card slap game or any
of the other awesome stuff in the gift
shop and get 10% off of all of it when
you go to david pakman.com slash impeach